uh i was unpacking a lot of stuff and
and
realizing within myself things that i
pushed down and said was okay that
weren't uh and trauma things were coming
up for me again i was doing a lot of
therapy
and uh so i started to write more for
myself and then
um stories that i was like i want to
tell these stories and i have why why
can't i more as like a producer like i
want to get someone to do this and i
think i realized if i can't write it's a
disadvantage and it would only help me
to learn how to right and for the
upcoming season of supergirl i really
wanted to tell a war vet story and
go a little deeper
uh in the sean aston kind of where we
started but like really explore it and
how do you do that because it sounds so
daunting that you know you get the show
going on for so many years
that you want to just jump in and write
an episode or
because where does it fit because you
got to think there's arcs and there's
episodes that lead into other episodes
and they're crossing into each other and
there's like then they have the malta
universe or whatever the arrowverse yeah
and all these things so
i mean it takes a lot of chutzpah the
chutzpah of like going in and like
writing an episode because that's you
sort of wrote a piece right yeah you
wrote an episode yeah
but but but again it was my version of
it had nothing to do with the storylines
on the show i knew what was happening
with my character because our showners
really did
end of season beginning of season told
you you're pretty much a whole arc so we
had a really good idea right okay that's
good
um
but again
so i i wrote this with that idea of that
also i was um
finding my voice a lot because
i've always been someone that never
wants to be difficult and to the to a
detriment of myself
and uh i was starting to realize that
speaking up for myself didn't make me
difficult um
and asking for things that i want was
something i had never really done i just
like i'm just happy to be here i don't
wanna
and i started realizing uh
that if i didn't do that that it wasn't
it wasn't gonna go well and anyone could
call you anything like no matter what
you're doing so you might as well like
stand and stand for yourself and and um
i started asking for things and
what were you asking for
i had called uh
my the shareholder and creator of jane
the virgin jenny ehrman and i i was
talking through some stuff with her
because i'm still very close with her
and i was like i want to make these
shows and these are my ideas and she
loved one of them and she was like let's
start developing it so so at the same
time we had brought in a writer that was
a friend of mine from jane and we were
doing these mini rooms and so we were
creating something um based on a time in
my life uh while i was writing this
super cool thing with this writing coach
so
it was very serendipitous in that by the
time i they were like we want you to
write an episode likely the storyline
that i had written
um
i was like okay i feel i just
worked with this genius woman creating
something from nothing i i think i could
i know these characters so well i've
been
on the show for a couple years now i
feel like so you pleaded this case to
them you really no no i this is all in
my head
my head is the wild plague okay
on the outside i was like here's the
sample i'd love to explore this i love
writing i've been working on it and then
they they really loved it they're like
we'll send this off and then our other
producers in the studio loved it and
then that was it pretty much yeah and
then kovit and then and then every like
life got complicated and coveted
stretched out longer melissa was having
a baby um uh and then we found out it
was our final season and so they had to
scrap the storylines and start over but
because they committed to an episode
they kept their word and
uh did you have to rewrite something
rewrite it oh i started from scratch so
i had to join the writer's room so i i
had to wait a minute so they scratched
the episode that you were going to do
the whole season all season because it's
all changed it's the final one they had
to redo everything for the third time
and so that had to be a little
disappointing since you wrote something
you're really happy with it now you had
to start from scratch and but they still
were interested i i was like this isn't
gonna happen anymore it's fine in my
mind this is their way of saying we like
you you're so sweet but no thanks and i
would get i would get you know it's the
final season of a show that's been on
for a long time
uh but but there was there was a
three or four episodes that i didn't do
because i joined the writers i really
feel like
i just kept showing up and uh were they
annoyed
no i think they were like pleasantly
surprised you just kept showing up every
day would you be quiet or would you be
assertive and go i have an idea what if
this happened yeah and they were cool
with that they're like this [ __ ]
actors in the room i would wait i would
wait until everybody spoke i would wait
until there was like a stall and then i
would really think about what i was
going to say and then i would i would
only try to offer solutions or with with
my character or kyle's character i felt
comfortable speaking up uh with
representation certain things like you
can't do that or
you know for this arc storyline let's
bring in guest stars
you know to make it more authentic we
and and things like that and they were
really well received but i'm really
close with that right i've always been
closer with our writers uh than than
anyone on the show so a lot of them were
my my friends so then you kept just
pitching these story ideas yeah and they
said we love it write it
yeah well we did i was in the room for a
month so we did
three episodes but broke the arcs for
three episodes all together and then as
we were doing it people were going off
running their episodes and then we broke
uh blind spots
pretty roughly but they gave me a lot of
leeway and then um i went off and wrote
it with uh jay who was the co-writer of
the episode
and uh wasn't that were you nervous
i think i
here's the thing
i do something and don't think about how
hard or scary it is until i'm like god i
wish i was you 85 in
and then i have a panic at 85 but i've
usually committed i have to do it and so
i'm like i'm almost there i've got to
just buckle down and then i push past
the last bit and what was the most
important thing when you were writing
this that you were thinking of that this
is what i want to come across this is
what i want people to understand because
i i felt like it was
it was really cool how you said
something about
the superheroes that they that they
they're part of the problem that
supergirl and
all her justice league they were part of
the problem
with racial injustice and all these
things that's that's a difficult
subject that's that's hard to tackle for
anyone yeah
yeah especially when you're you know
doing notes calls and in rooms and
this character has been built up as the
hero that's the best of everyone and and
then you have to you know it's it's it's
interesting to watch how people react to
those scenes when they're reading them
because it people get very um defensive
it's almost like it's them that is being
attacked
um
but
i
you bear down i did
you just said eff it i'm gonna do this
yeah
yeah and and i even with our fans i find
a lot of them
we were lacking empowerment of oneself
and it's like they're not superheroes
aren't going to save the day like the
whole point of this is that hopefully
you take some of that for yourself and
empower yourself we all have a superhero
in us yes we're all we all can be
superheroes yes by being good people yes
and not relying on someone to rescue you
in your everyday life this could be
translated to so many things wow um and
so what does it look like when you
expect someone to rescue and they fail
you like what how painful is that how do
you step up for yourself how do you show
up from yourself so
i think there were themes in it that
hopefully uh people that watch the show
that aren't like oh i'm not that so i
can't um it overwrote that
you